the spookiest time of year is quickly
approaching and if you're looking for a
gory movie marathon you could do a lot
worse than the Friday the 13th series
Friday may not be the father of the
slasher genre but it's definitely the
crazy uncle and the unstoppable Jason
Voorhees the signature hockey mask is
now one of the most recognizable icons
in American pop culture for newcomers
and hardcore fans alike we're running
down every Friday the 13th movie ranked
from worst to best after sprinting past
the events of the original film the 2009
reboot moves on to an adult Jason with
an intelligent cunning characterization
that seemed like a pointless change if
not an outright betrayal of the original
series
Jason's are seemingly supernatural
abilities are neatly explained away
callbacks to the previous films for
ridiculously flat and the Jason captures
a girl and holds her prisoner as if it
ever bother with mere kidnapping the
film had a so-so performance at the box
office but earned dismal reviews and a
lengthy tug-of-war over rights issues
helped sync another attempt at a reboot
this film simply shouldn't exist even
the worst entry from the original series
is preferable on that note
just one in a long line of films that
were meant to end the series Jason goes
to hell the final Friday and does the
mythology built by the previous entries
reinventing Jason as a vengeful spirit
that can only be killed by members of
his own bloodline using a special magic
dagger after being killed by the FBI in
the beginning
Jason spends most of the movie as a
spirit possessing random people by
forcibly installing his heart into their
chest cavity's it's only notable moments
come at the very end when an appearance
by a familiar knife gloved hand sets up
a much better movie that wouldn't show
up for another decade a film that
definitely fails to live up to its title
1989's Friday the 13th part 8 Jason
Takes Manhattan benefits only from the
presence of Kane Hodder in a second turn
as the man behind the mask a ridiculous
amount of the movie takes place in the
confines of a cruise ship or Jason's
actual romp through the Big Apple it
takes up perhaps 20 minutes at the
movies end you don't
there is a maniac trying to kill us
welcome to New York
of course director Rob Hedden had
intended something very different as he
explained in a making-of book jason was
supposed to murder his way through all
sorts of iconic New York locations
before jumping off the Statue of Liberty
but the measly five million dollar
budget wouldn't allow for any of that
instead of that awesome sounding movie
we got one of the most visually flat
tedious entries in the entire series
every long-running horror franchise
eventually embarrasses itself by sending
its villain into space so it's only
fitting that the final proper
installments of the original Friday the
13th series would do just that after
being captured by the government
Jason is placed into cryogenic stasis
for hundreds of years
revived by some students he weeks his
special brand of havoc on a spaceship
receives an insane cyborg upgrade and as
once again seemingly dispatched for good
despite its silly premise mm and once
Jason X is surprisingly solid with a
ferocious performance by Hodder and his
final outing and at least a couple of
the series most truly bizarre and
inventive kills a late film sequence
featuring cyborg Jason in a holodeck
like recreation of Camp Crystal Lake
it's also a nice touch and the features
are remixed a version of what hot accord
is favorite kill of all time which just
so happens to be featured in the next
entry despite being little remembered
1988 Friday the 13th part 7 the new
blood is noteworthy for marking Kane
Hodder's debut as Jason and also for the
infamous sleeping bag scene
the film's protagonist is Tina Shepard a
telekinetic younger woman who
inadvertently revives Jason from his
watery grave at the bottom of Crystal
Lake while trying to bring her drowned
father back to life many fans felt that
the Jason vs. Carey premise was a bit of
a stretch but harder held the film
together and the even helped the film
set a record for stunt work in the
film's climactic battle
Tina uses her powers to set Jason on
fire a scene that was achieved by having
hotter actually be on fire for a
whopping 40 seconds as the cameras
rolled his dedication to the role showed
LA and his Hut performance helps make
the new blood a solid entry it wasn't
until 2003 that fans hopes on the
promise made in the last few frames of
Jason goes to hell were finally
fulfilled
fortunately the movie of fans nightmares
ended up being worth the years long wait
while it isn't actually part of the main
Friday the 13th franchise the crossover
Freddy vs. Jason earns its place in the
list by virtue of being so awesomely
over-the-top
a Nightmare on Elm streets Freddy
Krueger is bummed that his memory among
the living is dying out making it harder
for him to invade the dreams of children
he decides to free Jason Voorhees from
hell and turn him loose on his old Elm
Street stomping grounds in the hopes
that the fresh wave of gruesome murders
will rekindle the legend of Freddy but
once Jason starts killing it's pretty
tough to get him to stop
so Freddy maneuvers Jason into a
showdown before he can kill off all the
Freddy's potential victims the film
works far better than it has any right
to after spending an eternity in
development hell the franchisor styles
mesh well and there are a couple of
genuinely creepy moments amidst the
carnage the fifth film in the series
1985 s Friday the 13th a new beginning
is a near-perfect Friday the 13th film
that fans absolutely hate for one
totally understandable reason the ending
of the movie reveals that the Jason is
been killing his way through a teen
rehab facility wasn't ever actually
Jason at all but just some random guy
specifically a paramedic upset over the
death of his son early in the film okay
the Jason copycats weak motivation was
especially disappointing considering the
interesting psychological thriller angle
the film takes before the reveal and our
teenage Tommy Jarvis who has a child put
a brutal end to Jason's reign of terror
with the murderers own machete is among
the residents at the home for troubled
teens when the murders begin anew the
implication that Tommy may be
responsible for his new round of mayhem
is teased throughout and his ultimate
faceoff of the Jason copycat is truly
nerve jangling but for most fans for
fake out sending wasted all the goodwill
the movie engendered with it's crazy
kills and high body count it all makes a
new beginning a very good franchise
entry with one king-sized floor that
ultimately shouldn't keep her from being
enjoyed the third entry in the Friday
the 13th franchise had the misfortune of
being produced in 1982 smack in the
middle of the early 80s 3d revival but
if you can get past all the unnecessary
3d shots that only exist to throw
something at the audience part three is
a tight suspenseful shocker that
features some jaw-dropping kills and
sees Jason put on his iconic hockey mask
for the first time the film's plusses
nothing special
Jason kills a bunch of teenage friends
and their biker gang rivals producers
toyed
the idea of definitively ending the
franchise with this entry scripting a
conclusion in which Jason's head is
lopped off by protagonist Chris but
ultimately Jason's fate has left hanging
after a nightmarish false ending that
illustrates how fake out dream sequences
should be done at a scant 87 minutes
1981 so Friday the 13th Part 2 is short
dark and efficient when the carnage
starts it comes fast and furious the
movie wastes no time in ceremoniously
dispatching alice the sole survivor of
the first film within its first few
minutes this installment Jason is a mute
ferocious beast and the means by which
he's defeated confusing him by invoking
the memory of his dead mother would
become a reliable means of at least
slowing him down in future entries in
the series despite the departure of the
first film special effects wizard Tom
Savini part to offer - sequences
creative enough to invoke the wrath of
the MPAA
who insisted that a total of 48 seconds
be cut to avoid an X rating it's still a
brutal relentlessly paced entry and a
worthy sequel to one of the greatest
slasher films of all time the film that
launched a seemingly unstoppable
franchise is actually more of a murder
mystery that most of the slasher flicks
it inspired the third act to reveal that
the killer is former camp Kirk misses
for he's driven insane by the drowning
death of her weirdo son Jason was
absolutely jaw-dropping as was her
ultimate fate thanks to the film special
effects genius Tom Savini according to
director Sean Cunningham Savini obsessed
endlessly over how to accomplish mrs.
Voorhees death scene and he also
designed the young Jason's look for his
surprise appearance at the end Friday
the 13th was a film born of pure
money-making opportunism but savvy knees
groundbreaking make-up effects work
turned it into a horror classic of
course it also doesn't hurt that the
performance of veteran actress Betsy
Palmer as mrs. Voorhees it's super
creepy kill her mommy
the second best film when the franchise
has at all tons of campy kills skin
crawling scares and great performances
all around the film opens with a
delirious sequence in which Tommy Jarvis
literally digs up Jason's grave on a
stormy night impales the corpse with an
iron steak from the cemetery's fence and
angrily tosses a hockey mask and machete
into the grave
anybody who's ever seen Frankenstein can
guess what happens next there's a freak
lightning strike and a newly reanimated
Jason an explicitly supernatural being
for the first time in the series goes on
a killing spree
the opening sets a self-referential tone
that continues throughout the movie
successfully making the audience's laugh
between the jump scares and brutal
murders the film is simply a blast the
body count is absurdly high and stuntman
CJ graham is second only to Kane Hodder
in his menacing portrayal of Jason it's
almost the best Friday the 13th ever
almost as the name suggests the fourth
installment of the series was indeed
intended to be the final one and if it
had been the franchise may have had a
completely different legacy the film
begins with Jason escaping the morgue
and getting set to embark on another
rampage before finally meeting as much
in an unlikely adversary Jason's our
soon-to-be longtime nemesis Tommy Jarvis
makes his first appearance as a 12 year
old played by a younger Corey Feldman
Tommy ends up saving a sister's life in
the film's nerve-wracking climax one of
the most intense and graphic final
scenes in any mainstream horror film ask
any truly hardcore fan and they'll tell
you the final chapter is a
quintessential Friday the 13th film
unbelievably brutal and at times
unbearably tense it's not only the best
film and the franchise but one of the
greatest slasher films ever check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite stuff are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]